solo por la forma en que se mueve parecer gentil y cariñosa,
y en otro caso, parecer violenta y conflictiva.
Y es la misma estructura, solo el movimiento es diferente.
Actor: "¿Quieres saber algo? Bueno, ¿Quieres saber algo?
¡Ya estaba muerto!
¡Ahí tirado, "ojos vidriosos"!
(Risas)
Pero, moverse con gracia solo es un bloque de construcción de toda esta estructura
llamada interacción humano-robot.
En ese momento estaba haciendo mi doctorado,
Estaba trabajando en la labor de equipo humano-robot;
equipos de humanos y robots trabajando juntos.
Estudiaba la ingeniería,
la psicología, la filosofía del trabajo en equipo.
Y al mismo tiempo me encontré
en mi propia situación de trabajo en equipo
con un buen amigo mío que incluso está aquí.
Y en esa situación fácilmente podemos imaginar robots
en un futuro próximo estando ahí con nosotros.
Fue tras un Seder de Pascua.
Estábamos doblando un montón de sillas plegables,
y me sorprendió lo rápido que encontramos nuestro propio ritmo.
Todos hicieron su parte.
No tuvimos que dividir nuestras tareas.
No tuvimos que comunicarnos verbalmente sobre esto.
Simplemente sucedió.
Y pensé,
seres humanos y robots no se parecen en nada a esto.
Cuando seres humanos y robots interactuan,
es mucho más como un juego de ajedrez.
El humano hace una cosa,
el robot analiza lo que hizo el humano,
entonces el robot decide qué hacer a continuación,
lo planea y lo hace.
Y entonces el humano espera, hasta que sea su turno otra vez.
Así que, es mucho más como un juego de ajedrez
y eso tiene sentido porque el ajedrez es genial
para los matemáticos y científicos de la computación.
Todo es cuestión de análisis de información,
toma de decisiones y planificación.
Pero yo quería que mi robot fuera menos un jugador de ajedrez,
y más como un hacedor
que solo hace click y trabaja en equipo.
Así que hice mi segunda terrible elección de carrera:
Decidí estudiar actuación durante un semestre.
Dejé el doctorado. Fui a clases de actuación.
De hecho participé en una obra,
Espero que no haya ningún vídeo de eso por ahí todavía.
Y conseguí todos los libros que pude encontrar acerca de la actuación,
entre ellos uno del siglo XIX
que conseguí de la biblioteca.
Y realmente me sorprendí porque mi nombre era el segundo nombre en la lista...
el nombre anterior era de 1889. (Risas)
Y este libro estuvo esperando durante 100 años
para ser redescubierto para la robótica.
Y este libro muestra a los actores
como mover cada músculo en el cuerpo
para coincidir con cada tipo de emoción que quieran expresar.
Pero la verdadera revelación fue
cuando aprendí acerca del método de actuación.
Se hizo muy popular en el Siglo XX.
Y el método de actuación decía, no tienes que programar cada músculo de tu cuerpo.
En vez de eso tienes que usar tu cuerpo para encontrar el movimiento adecuado.
Tienes que usar tu memoria de sensorial
para reconstruir las emociones
y pensar con tu cuerpo para encontrar la expresión correcta.
Improvisa, enfrenta a tu compañero de escena.
Y esto llegó al mismo tiempo que estaba leyendo sobre esta tendencia
en psicología cognitiva llamada cognición corporal.
Que también habla sobre las mismas ideas.
Usamos nuestros cuerpos para pensar,
no solo pensamos con nuestros cerebros y usamos nuestros cuerpos para movernos
sino que nuestros cuerpos se retroalimentan de nuestros cerebros
para generar la forma en que nos comportamos.
Y fue como un rayo.
Regresé a mi oficina.
Escribí este artículo, que realmente nunca publiqué
llamado "Clases de actuación para la Inteligencia Artificial."
E incluso me tomé otro mes
para hacer lo que entonces fue la primera obra de teatro
con un humano y un robot actuando juntos.
Eso fue lo que vieron antes con los actores.
Y pensé:
¿Cómo podemos hacer un modelo de inteligencia artificial?
computadora, modelo computacional,
que muestre algunas de estas ideas de improvisación,
de tomar riesgos, de arriesgarse,
incluso de cometer errores.
Tal vez pueda servir para mejorar compañeros de equipo robóticos.
Así que trabajé durante mucho tiempo en estos modelos
y los implementé en una serie de robots.
Aquí pueden ver un muy temprano ejemplo
con los robots tratando de usar esta inteligencia artificial corporal,
para tratar de coincidir con mis movimientos lo más parecido posible,
algo así como un juego.
Echemos un vistazo a esto.
Pueden ver cuando lo desestabilizó, lo engañe.
Y es un poco de lo que pueden ver que hacen los actores
cuando intentan reflejarse uno en el otro
para encontrar la correcta sincronía entre ellos.
Y entonces, hice otro experimento,
y conseguí gente de la calle para que utilizaran la lámpara de escritorio robótica,
y probaran esta idea de inteligencia artificial corporal.
Así que, en realidad usé dos tipos de cerebros para el mismo robot.
El robot es la misma lámpara que vieron,
y le coloque dos cerebros.
Para la mitad de las personas,
puse un cerebro que es una especie del tradicional,
cerebro robótico calculado.
Espera su turno, analiza todo, planea.
Llamémoslo el cerebro calculado.
El otro tiene más de actor de teatro, el cerebro que se arriesga.
Llamémoslo el cerebro aventurero.
A veces actúa sin saber todo lo que tiene que saber.
A veces comete errores y los corrige.
Y los puse hacer esta muy tediosa tarea
que tomó casi 20 minutos
y tenían que trabajar juntos.
De alguna manera simulando un trabajo de fábrica
de hacer de forma repetitiva lo mismo.
Y lo que descubrí fue que las personas en verdad amaban
a el robot aventurero.
Y pensaron que era más inteligente,
más comprometido, un mejor miembro del equipo
que contribuyó más al éxito del equipo.
Incluso lo llamaron 'él' y 'ella',
mientras que las personas con el cerebro calculado lo llamaron 'eso'.
Y nadie lo llamó 'él' o 'ella'.
Cuando hablaron de ello después de la tarea
con el cerebro aventurero,
dijeron: "Al final, fuimos buenos amigos y chocamos las manos mentalmente".
Lo que sea que eso signifique.
(Risas) Suena doloroso.
Mientras que las personas con el cerebro calculado
dijeron que éste era como un aprendiz perezoso.
Solo hizo lo que debía hacer y nada más.
Que es casi lo que la gente espera que los robots hagan,
por lo que me sorprendió que la gente tuviera mayores expectativas
de los robots, de lo que cualquiera en robótica pensaría que los robots deberían hacer.
Y en cierto modo, pensé, tal vez es hora...
al igual que el método de actuación cambió la forma
en que la gente pensaba de la actuación en el siglo XIX,
de pasar de una muy calculada,
planeada, forma de comportarse,
a una más intuitiva, arriesgada, corporal forma de comportarse.
Quizá sea hora de que los robots
tengan el mismo tipo de revolución.
Unos años más tarde,
me encontraba en mi siguiente trabajo de investigación en Georgia Tech, en Atlanta,
y estaba trabajando en un grupo que
lidiaba con músicos robots.
Y pensé, música, es el lugar perfecto
para observar el trabajo en equipo, coordinación,
sincronización, improvisación...
y solo teníamos este robot tocando marimba.
Marimba, para todos los que como yo no sepan
es este enorme, xilófono de madera.
Y, cuando miraba esto,
había visto otros trabajos en improvisación humano-robot...
sí, hay otros trabajos en improvisación humano-robot...
y también eran un poco como un juego de ajedrez.
El humano jugaba,
el robot analizaba lo que se tocaba,
improvisaba su propia parte.
Esto es a lo que los músicos llaman
una interacción de llamada y respuesta,
y también se ajusta muy bien, a los robots y la inteligencia artificial.
Pero pensé, si utilizo las mismas ideas que usé antes
en la obra de teatro y en los estudios de trabajo en equipo,
quizá pueda hacer que los robots toquen juntos
como una banda.
Todos tocando, nadie se detiene por un momento.
Y así que, intenté hacer las mismas cosas, esta vez con música,
donde el robot no sabe realmente
lo que se va a tocar.
Solo como que mueve su cuerpo
y utiliza algunas oportunidades para tocar.
Y hace lo que me enseñó mi maestra de jazz cuando yo tenía 17 años.
Decía, cuando improvisas,
a veces no sabes lo que estás haciendo
y lo sigues haciendo.
Así que intente hacer un robot que en realidad
no sabe lo que está haciendo, pero lo sigue haciendo.
Vamos ver a unos segundos de esta actuación.
Donde el robot escucha al músico humano
e improvisa.
Y luego, miren cómo el músico humano también
responde a lo que el robot está haciendo y aprende
de su comportamiento.
Y en algún momento incluso puede ser sorprendido con lo que hace el robot.
(Música)
(Aplausos)
Ser músico, no es solo hacer notas,
de otra manera nadie iría a ver un show en vivo.
Los músicos también se comunican con sus cuerpos,
con otros miembros de la banda, con el público,
usan sus cuerpos para expresar la música.
Y pensé, ya tenemos un músico robot en el escenario,
¿por qué no hacer que sea un músico completo?
Y empecé a diseñar una cabeza expresiva socialmente
para el robot.
La cabeza en realidad no toca la marimba,
solo expresa cómo es la música.
Estos son algunos bocetos en servilleta de un bar en Atlanta,
que estaba peligrosamente situado exactamente a la mitad
entre mi laboratorio y mi casa. (Risas)
Así que pasé, diría que en promedio,
de tres a cuatro horas al día ahí.
Creo. (Risas)
Y volví a mis herramientas de animación y traté de averiguar
no solo cómo se vería un músico robot,
sino sobre todo cómo se movería un músico robot.
Algo para demostrar que no le gusta lo que la otra persona está tocando...
y tal vez para mostrar cualquier ritmo que esté sintiendo
en el momento.
Así que terminamos consiguiendo el dinero para construir este robot, lo que fue muy bueno.
Voy a mostrarles ahora el mismo tipo de ejecución,
esta vez con una cabeza expresiva socialmente.
Y fíjense...
cómo el robot nos muestra
el ritmo que está adquiriendo de los humanos.
También le estamos dando al humano la sensación de que el robot sabe lo que está haciendo.
Y también cómo cambia la forma en que se mueve
tan pronto como comienza su propio solo.
(Música)
Ahora me mira para asegurarse de que estoy escuchando.
Y ahora, mira el acorde final de la pieza otra vez,
y esta vez el robot se comunica con su cuerpo
cuando está ocupado haciendo sus propias cosas.
Y cuando ésta listo
coordina el acorde final conmigo.
(Música)
(Aplausos)
Gracias. Espero que vean cuanto esto no...
qué tanto esta parte del cuerpo que no toca el instrumento
ayuda con la interpretación musical.
Estamos en Atlanta, así que obviamente algún rapero
entrará en nuestro laboratorio en algún momento.
Y entró este rapero
y realizó una pequeña actuación con el robot.
Y aquí pueden ver al robot
básicamente respondiendo al ritmo y...
observen dos cosas. Una, qué tan irresistible es
unirse con el robot mientras éste mueve su cabeza.
y como que quieren mover su cabeza cuando la mueve.
Y segundo, aunque el rapero está realmente centrado en su iPhone,
tan pronto como el robot se voltea hacia él, éste voltea también.
Así que aunque esta solo en la periferia de su visión.
solo en la esquina de su ojo, es muy poderoso.
Y la razón es que no podemos ignorar
cosas físicas moviéndose en nuestro entorno.
Estamos conectados para eso.
Así que si tienen un problema quizás con sus compañeros
que miran demasiado el iPhone o demasiado a su smartphone,
tal vez quieran tener ahí un robot
para llamar su atención. (Risas)
(Música)
(Aplausos)
Solo para presentarles al último robot
con el que hemos trabajado
que surgió de algo sorprendente que encontramos:
En algún momento a la gente ya no le importaba que el robot fuera tan inteligente,
y que pudiera improvisar y escuchar,
y que hiciera todas estas cosas de Inteligencia corporal que he pasado años desarrollando.
A ellos realmente les gustaba que el robot disfrutara la música. (Risas)
Y no dijeron que el robot se movía con la música,
dijeron que el robot disfrutaba la música.
Y pensamos, ¿por qué no tomamos esta idea?
y diseñé un nuevo artículo.
Esta vez no era una lámpara de escritorio; era una base de altavoces.
Era una de esas cosas en las que conectas tu smartphone.
Y pensé, qué pasaría
si su base de altavoces no solo reprodujera la música
si no que la disfrutara también. (Risas)
Y de nueva cuenta, aquí están algunas pruebas de animación
desde una etapa temprana. (Risas)
Y así es como lucía el producto final.
(Música "Drop It Like It's Hot")
Mucho movimiento de cabeza.
(Aplausos)
Mucho movimiento de cabeza en el público,
así que aún podemos ver, que los robots influencian a la gente.
Y no es solo diversión y juegos.
Creo que una de las razones por lo que me importan tanto
los robots que utilizan su cuerpo para comunicarse
y usan su cuerpo para moverse.
voy a contarles un secreto que nosotros los especialistas en robótica escondemos...
es que cada uno de ustedes va a vivir con un robot
en algún momento de su vida.
En algún lugar en su futuro va a existir un robot en su vida.
Y si no es en la suya, entonces en la vida de sus hijos.
Y quiero que estos robots sean...
sean más fluidos, más cautivadores, con más gracia.
de lo que actualmente parecen ser.
Y por eso creo que tal vez los robots
necesitan ser menos como jugadores de ajedrez
y más como actores en escena y más como músicos.
Tal vez deberían poder arriesgarse e improvisar.
Y tal vez deberían ser capaces de anticipar lo que estás apunto de hacer.
Y tal vez necesiten poder cometer errores
y corregirlos,
porque al final somos humanos.
Y tal vez al igual que los humanos, los robots son un poco menos que perfectos
son solo perfectos para nosotros.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)